he would become 1 teacher
so now the question points
he will no longer have an active memory of that
if you take 1 position in Europe
or at the world economic forum
or will Mark Rutte soon be your new teacher
there has been specialization in recent days
about what motivated me
the only answer is the Netherlands
my position to that is completely unsuitable
yesterday morning
I have made the decision that I am not again
available Be the leader of the VVD
when taking office
after the elections of 1 new cabinet
I will leave politics
and I HAVE yesterday afternoon
my party chairman and party chairman
set it at De Hoogte
that is my personal consideration
that is independent of developments in recent weeks
but I want you
tell at the start of this debate